so yeah this is a
a talk a super nerdy talk
about network and crypto and early phase
tinkering and all kinds of stuff
uh thanks for yeah man thanks for coming
uh i hack on compilers at a company
called igalia we do mostly
browser internals so if you ship webkit
or you should blink or you ship
you know node or v8 or something like
that and you want to participate in
making the web better for
your use case and for everyone you know
let's get in touch we can make it happen
we recently did the
generators work in v8 and adapted
the generator stuff that existed in
spider monkey to
work with the new es6 standard and that
was all sponsored by bloomberg
so that's the sort of stuff i normally
do and this is not a talk like that
right uh this is talk about crypto and
i'm not a cryptographer
and i'm not you know super network
engineer i'm just you know a tinkerer
and a nerd
and so i thought that you know i saw
this paper
and i was like damn i got to play around
with this thing right so
this is to talk about that so
the context we're in is you know the
context
of you've got generals peeping in on
your emails and your google searches
and you know if you search for the wrong
thing if you read the wrong thing
they'll send men with guns right this is
what they did you know recently if you
with a mother that was searching for a
new pressure cooker while the teenage
son
as one does was searching for the
anarchist cookbook
and you know they sent the swat team
right so
i mean this is just a freaky place to be
in you know
in the world it's just you know creepy
and disgusting and the
the thing it makes me think of more than
anything is that
that tom waits tune you know like what's
he building in there
he's got subscriptions to those rss
feeds he's been hacking on minima
lt we're in his router and we're in his
phone
and you won't believe what we saw from
the drone
what's he building in there what the
hell
is he building in there we have a right
to know
you know it's like these [ __ ] are
looking at you and
the real solution of course is to smash
the state and you know
overthrow the political systems that are
you know creating this reality we live
in right now
in the meantime you know
as you know people who make the raw
substance of the future we need to make
their jobs a bit more difficult
right and so let's talk about https
um https is you know it can be
fairly secure um it's seen a long good
life
and we'll we'll see you know even more
but if you're going to attack it you
know you have a number
of vectors at your disposal right now
that you know you didn't have
maybe you know five years ago you could
do some serious cryptanalysis work on
rc4 or something you could you know pay
off
the certificate authorities to issue you
a rogue certificate
and you could use javascript right in
the crime and beast attacks that we've
seen recently
there's been recent talk that you know
some implementations of tls have
backdoors
but i don't think these are you know the
the biggest vulnerability in https
because for me it's http
right it's it's the fact that you can
access services
uh in an encrypted fashion or a not
encrypted fashion and often we're doing
it
in such a way that everything can be
snooped on right so the biggest enemy
to me uh of https is http
and dan j bernstein has a
competition that that he and some other
folks are running to come up with a
next-generation stream cipher and they
he quotes a number of disasters and if
you go visit this webpage there's lots
of
interesting stories about you know
crypto systems that just broke
right and the worst kind of breaking is
when you just don't get any crypto at
all
right and and http has that sort of
uh side of things so i want to do a poll
i always like doing polls in my talks
so how many of you use the eff https
everywhere extension good job folks i
mean that's really great but obviously
you know it's not all of you and it's
not even me
right so how many of you ever use google
to search
you know using the normal http thing
like or
i get asked this in the reverse way so i
can't i'm confusing all of you but
you know i know i search sometimes often
usually
actually over just plain http and it's
just you know it's nast right
so there's actually a reason for this
though you know and i i think you know
you feel it yourself
and it goes down to you know actual
fundamental things about the internet so
i took a packet trace of my browser
which
you know i run linux as any you know
tinker and
hacker does and and i actually use
epiphany which is a browser built on
webkit 2 on the gnome system so i'm
super weirdo here but you know it's a
modern webkit to
build so this is very similar to what
you have in your browser so i
at zero milliseconds uh i did a get
to http uh to gnu.org right
so at zero milliseconds we send out this
syn packet right and the syn packets
saying hey
and then 130 milliseconds we get back
a packet from the server saying hey you
know it's exactly like when you pick up
the phone it's like hello hello
and from this we can compute in this
particular situation that i've got a 130
millisecond round trip time
or half of that would be the latency and
you know this is not going to go down
like this is bandwidths are
going to go up uh but this particular
kind of latency
obviously this is a transatlantic one
from you know my french home to
the server in boston um but it can't go
down below
you know a certain level that certain
level is you know if you were to take a
plane like a light speed plane
you know your latency would be 45
milliseconds so there is you know
something at which
you're not going to go down and so after
i get this synap
i can you know finally send off my you
know get me the page
uh later on i get the first packet in
the in the result and i can start to
parse it right
and so i realized okay i got some css
and some javascript and all the things
and so
i can't actually ask for anything else
over the same connection
so i fire off uh three uh in this
particular case
parallel connections so three more sim
packets go out to google.org
i finally get the end of my uh request
like the end of the response
uh back at 410 milliseconds and then in
super sad panda mode
you know i finally get my parallel
connections opened after i've
gotten uh the first document and only
then can i make the other round trip
necessary to actually start fetching
uh the auxiliary resources so i mean
this is our internet and you know
i don't know this is half a second and
it's horrible uh
yeah so this is even not very many bytes
so it's not a bandwidth question at all
it's completely latency driven and of
course you know with https as we all
know it it just gets much worse
so syn i get back my synap i sent off my
you know client hello thing server comes
back and says hello we do the
certificate exchange stands
this particular case and this just blew
my mind when i when i saw it
for some reason we wait for the ack for
the server
to that it received our certificate
exchange packet to then
send another thing saying change cipher
and i don't know if this is a bug in my
networking stack or if it's something
more fundamental
because i wasn't intending to you know
do a deep investigation on tls in this
particular case but
i don't know this is a sort of you know
multiple round trips thing to set up a
secured
network uh connection that it's really
horrible i can i can only start to send
my request you know i've been talking
back and forth and back and forth
and wasted an entire half a second right
i would have gotten the result before
using http but i'm only now just asking
for it using https
to finally get back the result at almost
a second and and only now
you know only at that half a second the
when i get back the first packet which
is somewhere in between this 583 and
764 milliseconds are we are we actually
starting to kick off the parallel
connections which do the same thing uh
times three
you know and this is why it's slow like
this is why the internet is slow and
it's fundamental
because i'm doing the syn ack dance for
nothing
right for nothing you know i i'm saying
you know hello hello establish me a
connection and it's not even secure
so there is re there is room here for
a protocol which provides properly
implemented strong crypto
a phrase which you might recognize from
the first snowden interview
like that this is what works right
properly implemented strong crypto
that connects faster than tcp right like
this is a possibility
so this is something that probably will
happen at some point and this particular
talk is a kind of
early technological preview uh the the
pre-print on this paper for minimum lt
this new protocol
uh just came out in may so it's it's
early days yet
uh still you know making and breaking
but you know
this could be a sort of future glimpse
on the internet
so i want to talk about the two parts
the properly implemented strong crypto
part
and the faster than tcp part um
minimalt uses the high level knackle
library it's actually pronounced salt
i always say mackerel from djb
and tanya lang hashbreaker and
hyperliptic on the crypt
on the twitters and uh doing a fresh
protocol
actually can make things much more
secure because you can
design things sensibly from the ground
up you don't have to include
like a bunch of broken ciphers you don't
have to include
the null cipher you know the the
opportunity to make a connection in a
plain text mode
you can make sure that by default your
implementations of the
crypto primitives are not vulnerable to
these various timing
attacks that we've been seeing recently
and um
i don't know it's just like an
opinionated high-level
uh based on on which to work and the
salt library has been out and crypto
analyzed a bit and
still relatively new you know but but it
seems like a solid thing
and on top of that minimum lt adds a
forward secrecy layer so that
if someone breaks into either side and
manages to get
all the private keys on the server or
the client
they won't be able to decrypt a previous
connection
so that's that's what that is and it's
minimal latency
right the equivalent of dns and minimum
lt includes a sort of equivalent
to dns requires one round trip and
otherwise
zero in theory you can send your sort of
hello packet which opens the connection
and include the equivalent of the http
get request
in that first packet so you don't
actually need a round trip in the
beginning
and furthermore your connection can be
it's actually a tunnel there are
connections inside tunnels
your tunnel can be persistent they can
live a long time
it can persist over ip changes
so you don't need to do some particular
parts of the the protocol setup
every time you work so you can start
working
at home like reading your twitters or
whatever and you get on the train and
as the gsm changes your ip you know it's
it's still persisting on the same tunnel
uh
without seamlessly changing you over ips
without needing the application layer
to uh do recovery and reconnection logic
so it can it can make things a lot
faster in that case
and in addition you know so you're
designing a protocol today
you have to base it on udp or tcp right
otherwise it doesn't get through the
internet
and minimal t is based on udp it adds a
reliability layer so it's
sort of equivalent to tcp's reliability
um
it uh adds crypto as well so it sort of
folds in
what would be a tls layer as well so it
packs them in into one sort of
layer violating protocol but you know
i think it comes with a lot of
advantages and and it seems to be okay
it's also resistant to denial of service
attacks which is
another uh important detail when
designing
there's sort of a family of this kind of
protocol coming out right now and
and resistance to denial of service is
one thing that that all of them are
struggling with and minimum lt seems to
have a good solution although there are
some
some details we'll touch on a little bit
later and it's fast it's really fast
it's really fast um when you when you're
you know
running full speed you can saturate your
multiple gigabit links and uh it can
connect at very high rates as well
so we'll poke at that so they're tunnels
and connections
inside the tunnel the first time you
create the tunnel you have one
connection it's connection zero
it's a distinguished connection and
that's the one that actually
allows you to create other connections
so you would make
you know your tunnel and you would say
open me a connection to the http service
and then on that connection which you
provide that connection number
you would say get me index.html and at
the same time you could add
open other connections and get other uh
resources
um also connection zero is for
authentication the minimality includes
something that's like client-side
certificates
um it's an equivalent basically but i
won't go more into that
and um the multiple connections uh yeah
can proceed at the same time
although the precise congestion control
details
uh differ a little bit from quick which
is a new protocol from google that's
very similar
so you might want to google both of
these to
get more information about them quick
seems a bit more uh interested
in that a packet loss
that affects in the beginning doesn't
delay uh
parallel resource loading in the end
whereas minimality seems to be more
interested in
total ordering of uh all of the packets
even between connections so they're
totally ordered but again see the paper
for details
so it wouldn't be a crypto nerd you know
networking protocol talk without some
ascii art so i'm just busting that out
right now
i didn't i didn't have inkscape at the
time that i was making this and so i did
an ascii art and i'm like that's awesome
i'm leaving that so
there are two parts to a packet right
there's the cleartext part and the
ciphertext part and the clear text
includes your ethernet headers and your
ip headers and your udp headers
and that's 42 bytes in addition there
are 16 more bytes
half of that identifies the tunnel and
half of that is a nonce
nonce is actually an english word and i
didn't know that
and so it means like the moment the now
you know and it's also pronounced
number used once because that's the
thing it's like a number that just keeps
on incrementing
and you combine it with your secret so
you can prevent replay attacks that's
basically what that's for
and in addition the first packet
includes your ephemeral public key which
as you can see is only 32 bytes
which is the wild thing about elliptic
curve cryptography you can have keys
that aren't like
you know 20 48 bits long they're only
256 bits long or something like that
so that that goes out in the first
packet to establish the shared secret
and then later the tunnel id identifies
a shared secret for the server
and in the cipher text you include the
flow control fields the sec
the sequence number and the
acknowledgement field those are the ones
in tcp
that allow tcp to be reliable
reliability is a layer you know on top
of the protocol of communicating with
those fields so that's actually that can
be done in user space and that is super
rad
i was like you know how do you make a
reliable protocol because i didn't know
you know and then i saw that it's just
layered over this field and you have
this round trip
timer and you estimate how many bytes
are in flight and this is totally
something you know anybody can hack up
and do
so that's one of the points of this
presentation is like you know there's
room for new protocols
and we can hack them in user space you
know we can hack them and know you know
and we can experiment with different
congestion control protocols and
and that's a thing man that's totally a
thing so after that
so so after that we got the payload you
know that's that's your application data
on the crypto side the the the
ciphertext
is a box which is a concept from the
salt library
uh it's a public key system and so you
have a public private key exchange
obviously you keep your
your private keys and you exchange your
public keys and in a way that you
establish a shared secret combine that
with a nonce and
and authenticate and encrypt the buck so
it's completely tamper proof it's at a
higher level than
than most uh crypto primitives it's
built on top of other crypto primitives
in an opinionated way by dj bernstein
and tanya lang so it's like
you know check right but the the shared
secret is this public key exchange which
takes some bytes right
takes this you know larger um 32 byte
key
and and the 32 byte keys and combines
them so we actually trim
you know we don't have to send that at
each packet you do that
shared secret establishment in the
beginning and then the server identifies
associates a 64-bit identifier with that
larger
shared secret on the server side that's
the tunnel id
and there's a protocol to sort of change
your tunnel id periodically
so that you know passive analysis can't
track your connection over
ip movements although if you control the
entire internet like some [ __ ] do
you know maybe maybe that's a thing so
it's a public key system
and that's the problem right you know
how how do you distribute public keys
it's just a big old mess
right so in tls as we know the mess goes
like this your
your client knows the address of a dns
provider the dns provider gives the
address of the server
may you know there's no authentication
or anything in that right it's total
hackable thing the client connects to
the server
directly and the server gives it you
know its key and then the client
checks that key against the list of
known roots which is also
you know a hackable thing
in minimal lt it's a little bit
different the client knows the address
of the directory service which is like
dns
and and the directory service the
servers register with the directory
service and the the client
connects to the directory service over a
minimum lte connection because it knows
its long-term public key
and makes a minimum lte query for that
server's
address and current ephemeral public key
they're ephemeral because they they
change for
ford security and then it gets that back
and with that information they can then
connect directly to the server without a
round trip i'm kind of breezing through
this stuff because you know
i'm burning through time but the paper
is super interesting and and check it
out
so um yeah i'll skip that bit for
performance
uh the expensive part of the whole thing
is this initial establishment of the
shared secret like that's
that's the only thing that just costs a
lot of resources
yo and uh so
minimum lte can do about 8 000
connections per core on a modern x86
system
and extrapolates from some other numbers
that they have i think it's about 750 on
an arm device although i haven't tried
and then afterwards it can go quite fast
so
why does tcp need a three-way handshake
um and why can minimum lt avoid it well
one you know in a
in a connection flooding attempt
minimality can force the client to sort
of effectively mine for bitcoins like
given this secret produce another value
that with when combined with it
has a hash whose three low bits are zero
or something like that
you know forcing the client to pay
computationally
for the ability to connect to the server
and
in addition if you have a request to an
unloaded server
and you just give back a response
directly the protocol is designed
ideally that the response would be
smaller than the request so you can't
use the server's resources
to attack a third party although that's
that's really the result of this js comp
for me
i was talking with folks and then i
realized you know is that right
you know can is are zero round-trip
protocols
actually compatible with defending
against amplification attacks
and that's not clear to me you know the
the paper sort of glosses over but
that's it's definitely not clear to me
because it's not
authenticated when you get a packet that
it comes from that ip
because the authentication corresponds
to the fact that it comes from this
public key but not that
when you reply to the ip that's in the
packet that it will be to the person who
sent it
and so if you include a request like get
you know whatever file in your first
packet
you're going to fill up the window and
the tcp window is you know 5 or
16 kilobytes or on that order you know
in your response which is a
pretty big amplification and i'm not
sure
i probably don't understand the things
and this is where i'm not a
cryptographer and all this stuff
it's also where the protocol is really
new in any case
if it is the case that you require a
round trip it's still not a total lose
because you are not worse than tcp in
the worst case
and in the the best case where you have
a tunnel established already
you you don't need that round trip so
so in that in that regard zero
round-trip uh
connections are always faster than tcp
at any
network latency over half a millisecond
which i mean damn
right and it always connects faster than
open ssl
obviously for the round-trip uh time
reasons
so uh very briefly for uh before i nail
this up this project is new
um it's associated with a research
project at a university of illinois
chicago
uh and their main thing is not minimal t
it's this new operating system called
ethos it's built on the zen hypervisor
and
and it's kind of complicated and new and
stuff and and
and john solar is the main fellow and
michael patel is doing the minimum lt
part
and mmlt is best conceived though for
them as a way of they do
typed ipc uh interim process
communication in their
in their operating system and for them
minimality is a way of like
transferring that you know to the remote
case and and so they're
i think they're thinking about more
authenticated connections between hosts
but in any case it's a mess right
because you got you know this new
operating system
and you've got to build it and it's
built with a fork of an old version of
go that doesn't compile anymore and
linux side as well you have libraries
building for both and
i mean i worked on it i worked on i
worked on it and i just i
i wanted to give you all a node library
but i didn't make it
uh so i'm getting there though i'm
getting pretty close
the posix api i think is going to look
more like this
what they do i'm going to go back a
little bit they they have these typed
ipc's
but the type um the way to establish
these types between the
the two sides for me it's kind of more
complicated than i care about right now
you know i'd rather like an api that
allows me to just sort of write uh data
on top of a lower level protocol and i
don't have to you know convert
everything to this new api
so that that's that's what i'm working
on should have out soon and
the javascript tie-in is that you need
an event loop running
in order to manage your your window and
your re retransmit times and stuff like
that
so libya v is a is an obvious and
awesome you know
thing to to think about right there and
you could talk about
you know actually uh just
basing it on salt and other uh things
there like progressively rewriting parts
that are in
uh c right now into javascript like the
whole
reliability layer i think that would be
super awesome right to have the
pure javascript congestion control
running on you know
authenticated uh encryption uh flow
control fields so that would be
super awesome so ending message is that
bandwidth's going up
latency is staying the same there's a
space for a protocol
that offers a strong crypto
at low latencies you can you know
you can lower your latencies by by a
large percentage i think it's on the
order of
you know 20 to 50 on on connections
uh it's a new thing go forth and hack
the minimum lt
this is the first presentation about
this project anywhere that i know of
uh and the next one is going to be here
in berlin in november
at the acm uh computer and communication
security conference
so they're actually presenting uh the
paper of which the preprint came out in
may
so synack just say no i'll be on the
twitters
at andy wing and i'll tweet these slides
and give an update on
on on the release so thanks very much
you